i put it this way gang banging isn't
uh being a member of a gang let's say
that isn't wrong you know what i'm
saying it's the it's the culture
not the overall culture it's the
activity it's how it's done it's the
lack of connection between the big
homies who know better and the young
homies who got something to prove you
know and
and that's just not again it's not just
a gang banging thing because outside of
gangbanging in other cities we still
find the violence we still find of
course the same problems
it's just a community thing a culture
thing
first and then um
[Music]
so i have i have a heart for people like
i feel like
it's human instinct to connect to build
to form organizations to or you know
outside of gangbanging in africa we had
tribes you know what i'm saying and one
tribe over here might not get along with
the tribe over here so it's not me
preaching against gang banging it's more
so
preaching against the ignorance that
makes us organizing uh
them versus us type thing